this video is brought to you by full
sail university
what's up guys michael here now have you
ever used a self checkout at the grocery
store while legally stoned and wondered
am i inadvertently contributing to
someone losing their job is technology
like this only further devaluing human
labor is it ethical to enter the code
for regular bananas when i am buying
organic bananas and will my partner one
day replace me with a self-checkout
machine or for those of you who don't
live in places with legalized plant
medicines is automated technology like
self-checkouts or those scary boston
dynamics robots eventually going to run
us all out of a job
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on automation are the robots winning but
before we get into it i want to tell you
about today's sponsor full sail
university what's up guys so we are in
winter park florida at full sail
university we are here to check out all
the amazing programs they have all the
cool stuff students are working on so
let's check it out full sail specializes
in preparing students for careers in
entertainment media and emerging
technologies they have degree programs
in areas like film and television music
and recording art and design games and
so much more and unlike most
universities where you're mostly
spending your time in lecture halls full
sales students have access to everything
from 3d printing labs to professional
music recording studios to an entire
backlot to use for film and tv projects
they also just opened a new virtual
studio that utilizes the same technology
used to make shows like the mandalorian
and the book of boba fett and we were
lucky enough to get to attend the grand
opening of the new studio and check it
out i even got to chat with the team who
runs it we've kind of taken this from
just some blank led screens yeah three
months ago to this interactive
environment they also have an entire
program in esports including full sail
armada an esports team that competes in
call of duty league of legends rocket
league and more and unlike any college i
ever attended full sail has its own
esports arena the full sail university
orlando health fortress and it is the
largest collegiate esports arena in the
entire country we got to check it out
and it did not disappoint okay guys if
you want to learn more about everything
happening here at full sail head to
fullsail.edu or click the link in the
description and now back to the show now
automation has become something of a
looming threat in recent years but it
isn't really a new thing in fact the
first american factories started
incorporating automated technology
almost a hundred years ago much of
america's post-war industrial boom was
fueled by the twin efficiencies of
fordism aka that infamous assembly line
of humans and technology but things got
even more automated starting in the
computer-fueled 70s as early algorithms
started to take up much of the busy work
that humans used to do presumably with a
giant calculator and lots of legal pads
and since then it's been a pretty
straight shot towards intensified
automation so if this has been a
gradually growing process for almost 100
years
why are people getting so freaked out
about it now the simplest answer is
technology is getting a lot more
sophisticated while we
stay pretty much the same and the stats
are bleak according to one oxford study
47 of jobs in the us are at high risk of
automation and a more recent study from
the 38 country economic coalition the
oecd predicts that 14 percent of oecd
jobs are at high risk by some accounts
by 2035 two thirds of american jobs will
be obsolete so just to future proof this
video real quick hey fellow robots once
you finish drinking the blood of a human
baby be sure to like and subscribe okay
we're back
now reactions to this predicted wave of
automation are varied for some these
changes are simply inevitable technology
is always developed in ways that shift
the landscape of human labor and if
anything this is the natural outcome of
all of those commercials telling people
to get degrees in stem for others the
future of automation is something that
should be keeping us up at night because
if 65 of workers are obsolete what are
they gonna do for the automation doomers
we're headed towards a dystopian future
where a small percentage of the
well-to-do ride around in their
self-driving cars on the way to a
sex-bot orgy at their friend jeff's
house obviously yeah it's jeff bezos
meanwhile the rest of us scrape together
nickels from the sewer in hopes of
buying a freshly robot prepared chipotle
burrito and yeah in this dystopian
future guac will still be extra and
these aren't fringe worries either in
the 2020 democratic primary andrew
yang's entire political platform was
centered around the necessity of
mitigating the economic effects of
automation specifically he called for
ubi or universal basic income which we
have a video about fyi and ubi is a
common feature of discussions of
automation with some arguing for it as a
sort of economic harm reduction measure
for those whose jobs will be eradicated
by algorithms meanwhile other more based
theorists argue that ubi could be the
basis of a utopian future where we all
reap the benefits of robot labor at this
point we need to ask ourselves is
paradigm shifting automation really
inevitable and if so is it going to ruin
your life in particular well maybe not
one school of thought on automation
sometimes called accelerationism argues
that full automation isn't something to
be feared and something to be actively
pursued in their book inventing the
future nick cyrnic and alec williams
write our first demand is for a fully
automated economy using the latest
technological developments such an
economy would aim to liberate humanity
from the drudgery of work while
simultaneously producing increasing
amounts of wealth and this is how
automation can finally help us realize
economist john maynard keynes's
prediction that by 2030 we would all be
working 15 hour weeks or three hour days
due to the efficiency of technology to
the question but won't automation ruin
all of our jobs cyrodic and williams
utilize the main lesson from everyone's
first improv class and say yes and in
doing this it will create a world where
work is no longer necessary according to
their argument automation doesn't have
to be something that lies in the hands
of a small crew of tech bros and
multinational corporations instead it's
something that should be held in the
commons so that its benefits can be
shared by all and in making this
argument theorists also call them to
question the old deeply american
assumption that work is an essential
feature of human life and that without
it we'd all be lazy bastards like an
idiocracy or futurama if i wasn't so
lazy i'd punch you in the stomach for a
quick philosophical detour on the value
of work thinkers as far apart as
aristotle and marx have both argued that
work is essential to what it means to be
human and that we can't fully actualize
our humanity if we're not engaging in
some type of labor so this means that
philosophically speaking it's good to
have jobs right not necessarily when
they say work they are talking about
human consciousness externalizing itself
by working on the world outside of
itself so uh if you enjoy spending a day
in the park working on your drawings of
birds that's work staying up late to
learn how to play your favorite songs on
the fugle horn
work reading a wikipedia page about the
fall of the roman empire so you can
argue that it's all happening again you
guessed it work so when theorists argue
for the end of work they're really
arguing for the end of wage labor i.e
the necessity of performing labor for
someone else so that you can make enough
money to not die okay philosophical
detour over while they acknowledge that
a world without work might be far away
serenic and williams do think that we
can at least begin to taste a bit of
that good life today by shifting towards
a four-day work week this has also been
argued by authors kyle lewis and will
strong in their recent book overtime why
we need a shorter work week for lewis
and strong shifting to a four day work
week is not only the obvious and ethical
move in response to increased automation
but it actually makes financial sense as
well
according to a report by the autonomy
think tank of which strong and lewis
remembers after a trial of a four-day
work week in iceland 86 of the country's
workforce are now working shorter hours
or gaining the right to shorten their
hours productivity remained the same or
improved across the majority of trial
workplaces and workers well-being
dramatically increased across a range of
indicators from perceived stress and
burnout to health and work-life balance
so if these thinkers are right then all
we need is a super no big deal gradual
revolution in which the people
reappropriate automated technologies
while developing new and better
technologies all at the aim of
alleviating labor time so that humans
can experience lives of flourishing all
made possible by robots algorithms and a
hearty dose of ubi
easy
right yeah not so much and it's not just
that recent years have left us less than
hopeful about some type of humanist
political revolution it's also that
robots suck at making burgers as gavin
muller writes in futures of work in
march 2018 flippy a burger flipping
robot was rolled out at the pasadena
location of fast food chain cali burger
to great fanfare and numerous headlines
the implication was clear would this
humble machine spell the end of the fast
food job the metonym for low skilled
entry level occupations
not exactly in an event that provoked
far less press coverage flippy was
retired after one day of work and whose
fault was this according to caliburger
it was the dumb humans of course they
argued that their workers clumsy fingers
were too slow to dress the burgers among
other tasks which as muller put it
caused flippy's meaty achievements to
pile up never mind that some journalists
had already noticed that flippy actually
wasn't very good at its job caliburger
was ready to protect flippy at all costs
if the robots can't make fast food
burgers it seems like we're a long way
off from full automation and this
complicates the narrative about us all
becoming obsolete mueller also discusses
the concept of consumer labor which
describes the work we end up doing when
we use things like self-checkouts in
these scenarios rather than abolishing
work automation proliferates it by
isolating tasks and redistributing them
to others expected to do it for free
digital technologies contribute to
overwork so a lot of what passes for
automation is really just passing the
buck to consumers think about it when we
use self checkouts we're just the ones
doing the exact same job that a
traditional checkout worker would be
doing except of course we do it for free
and things get even more insidious when
we consider companies like samasource
which utilizes cheap labor in developing
countries to feed repetitive data into
machine learning systems these low-wage
workers are thus the ghosts hidden in
the automated algorithms that we're
meant to believe are on a fast track to
making human cognitive labor obsolete
the company's ceo laila janna even
argues that paying these workers super
low wages is actually a moral thing to
do if we were to pay people
substantially more than that we would
throw everything off that would have a
potentially negative impact on the cost
of housing and the cost of food in the
communities in which our workers thrive
it seems like many of the automated
technologies of the future aren't much
more than glorified theranose machines
offering the illusion of futuristic
technology while just obscuring the
types of traditional labor making it all
possible and speaking of things that
automation will never replace i can't
imagine any robot ever matching the
soulless and spiritually cavernous
baritone of elizabeth holmes at the
highest level we didn't have the right
leadership in the laboratory but the
skepticism about the automated future
gets even more
well skeptical and the work of aaron
beneno in his book automation and the
future of work bennanov argues that the
narrative about the radical job losses
sure to be caused by automation is
largely overblown and as the result of
journalists and scholars over
emphasizing the importance of
productivity rates i.e the ratio of
labor outcome to employment and
underemphasizing output rates i.e a
measure of the volume of production in
terms of value added the narrative
around automation has been that it's
driven up productivity at the expense of
workers i eat because we're now so
productive we don't need workers anymore
but benanov notes that in the 2010s
there was basically zero percent growth
in manufacturing productivity according
to this logic actual productivity rates
don't support the narrative about
automation radically changing the
economy according to beninov no absolute
decline in levels of manufacturing
production has taken place but there has
been a decline in the output growth rate
with the result that output is growing
more slowly than productivity this
basically means that the reason we have
fewer jobs isn't because of automation
fueled productivity it's because
manufacturing output is declining and in
general when output is up jobs are up
and when output declines so does job
creation benenov also notes that the
countries with the highest rates of
automation have some of the highest
employment rates in the manufacturing
sector arguing that in the context of
intense global competition high degrees
of robotization have given firms
competitive advantages allowing them to
take market share from firms in other
countries thus germany japan and south
korea have some of the highest levels of
robotization they also have the largest
trade surpluses in the world workers in
european and east asian firms know that
automation helps preserve their jobs at
the same time countries like the united
states and the united kingdom have both
lower rates of robotic automation and
fewer workers employed in manufacturing
basically we might actually be more
competitive in manufacturing if we had
higher rates of automation but hey at
least we have baseball and the brits
have the queen who definitely isn't dead
so you win some you lose some now
benenov isn't arguing that automation
isn't increasing but rather that it's
already been increasing for decades and
it hasn't led to the radical shifts in
society that some have predicted for
that matter he says what automation
theorists describe as the result of
rising technological dynamism is
actually the consequence of worsening
economic stagnation productivity growth
rates appear to rise when in reality
output growth rates are falling however
benanov isn't arguing that everything is
chill and that the automation theorists
are just a bunch of boys crying wolf
because even if automation is not itself
the primary cause of a low demand for
labor it is nevertheless the case that
in a slow growing world economy
technological changes within a near
future horizon may still threaten large
numbers of jobs with destruction and a
context of economic stagnation and
slower rates of job creation so while
things aren't looking peachy through his
glasses either he doesn't think
automation is the sole boogeyman and
this is where his research seems to
bring us back to the work of cyrnic and
williams and strong and lewis all of
whom call for us to utilize the benefits
of increased automated technologies to
decrease our work weeks and labor time
as we've seen with studies in iceland
it's already possible for people to work
less without sacrificing productivity
and it's making those people way happier
in the process but if automation isn't
going to cause a labor apocalypse
tomorrow then we should use this time to
push for things like a four day work
week and all in all it seems like the
two potential futures offered to us by
automation are either a slightly worse
version of the status quo or a future
where we're at least all working a
little less we know we threw a lot of
complicated jargon at you today but
worry not as we have a couple of
resources to help first off there's an
exclusive interview that our friend
helen did with aaron benenov where he
explains his critique of the automation
theorist in detail so be sure to click
the link in the description and check
that out and if you want to hear more
about the work of strong and lewis and
their call for a four day work week i
interviewed them both a few months back
and you can check out the whole thing by
clicking the link in the description and
of course be sure to check out both of
their books as well and maybe the real
takeaway from all of this is that you're
technically doing work when you use the
self-checkout of the grocery store so if
you just happen to enter the code for
the cheapest fruit or produce item it's
usually bananas to buy something more
expensive
you've earned it but what do you guys
think is automation going to render
human labor obsolete
or are things a little more hopeful than
the doomsayers are telling us let us
know in the comments
huge thanks to our patrons for
supporting our labor and be sure to
check out our updated patreon page slam
that subscribe button like you're
joyfully clocking out for the weekend on
a thursday and don't forget to ring that
bell and as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]